mais là mais madame monsieur bonsoir il
a neigé abondamment sur notre région
pendant ce week-end et la circulation
devient de plus en plus dangereuse aussi
nous vous proposons de suivre ce soir
une enquête réalisée à ce sujet et
puisque nous sommes lundi le sport ne
sera bien sûr pas oublié puisque vous
pourrez assister aux résumés film et
d'un match de rugby qui s'est déroulé
dans notre région
hier mais avant de vous laisser en
compagnie d'andré de fort jacques qui
vous présentera dans un instant nos
informations nous allons voir ensemble
les prévisions de la météorologie
aujourd'hui après d'importantes chutes
de neige le temps s'est améliorée avec
des jeunes partiel en plaine l'après
midi voici les températures relevées
aujourd'hui à 13 heures
aurillac 4 clermont ferrand ii le puy -
un vichy 0 le pilot d'au moins 9 degrés
demain temps assez beau peu nuageux à
nuageux et brumeux le matin
vent variable faible température
maximale en hausse avec des jeunes
l'après-midi +3 à +5 degrés après gelée
matinale assez forte en montagne même
temps une nouvelle perturbation venant
du sud-ouest abordera les cévennes en
fin de journée vont à 15 cents mètres
secteur ouest 50 à 60 kilomètres/heure
l'isotherme 0° au sol le matin s'élevant
à 500 et 600 mètres l'après midi je vous
invite à présent à prendre connaissance
de la carte de l'état des routes
sur l'ensemble de la région les routes
demeurent dangereuses par suite de la
neige fondante et de la formation locale
de verglas en fin de nuit
l'école de diane et du guéry sont
ouverts à la circulation
mais l'utilisation de pneus spéciaux et
de neige est vivement conseillé lumières
clignotantes les col de la croix
saint-robert chemin départemental 36 et
du pas de peyrol sont fermées à la
circulation
lumières fixe sur la carte présentés
figurent dans les toiles et les zones
enneigées est hachurée les parties
susceptibles d'être verglacée voici
l'heure de nos informations